[Music]  oh my god my dad's almost here can  somebody help you this  [Music]  all right just stay there i'll get it  thanks  [Music]  man can you help me with this too  oh thanks man  hey dude let me put the pepper man so  we're there  where's there oh hold on  thanks man no problem  dinner is sir  hope she likes it  sweet mukha  uh no i only made enough for my dna  what  i have child now you're ditching me like  this teaching you what am i talking  about no no i get it it's fine i'll  leave it  [Music]  a few moments later  this is so romantic yeah i'm so glad  that you're here like  sometimes  can someone help me with this can you  help me with this too  where's there  how do you cook it  dude  do you wanna get some desserts  and i already sweet enough  [Music]  youtube go get your own room  hello okay thanks bye